in Duisburg mercedes-benz has presented
the third generation of its top-selling
sprinter a lot has changed since it
first hit the streets in 1995 but one
thing has remained the same the van has
as wide a range of applications as ever
[Music]
as Emmanuel Schaefer points out the
sprinters lent its name to the entire
segment but it's much more versatile
than an ordinary transporter whether you
carry people or goods or use it as a
weekend camper or for customer service
mercedes wanted to cover all the bases
the new mercedes-benz is available as a
panel van pickup or tour and offers a
choice of three chassis x' the interior
is lean and uncluttered just as we've
come to expect all controls for the
multimedia and driver assistance systems
are right on the steering wheel but
Mercedes still offers plenty of
variations over 1,700 different
combinations the Sprinter is also
impressive on the road it came onto the
market with five engines to choose from
as well as front rear or all-wheel drive
the all-wheel drive comes with a 7-speed
automatic transmission
and to guarantee smooth sailing in the
future the sprinters adapting its drive
to go with the times
the Alecto amana will explains the
importance of electric drive not only
for passenger cars but also for
transport vehicles and this new Sprinter
has an electric model coming out soon as
well
Natha selfie month of course the East
printer can be customized for a broad
range of purposes
[Music]
it can carry three of four battery
elements depending on requirements for a
range of 150 to 200 kilometers
what's more the new Sprinter is also
safer and more networked than previous
generations
[Music]
[Applause]
my country poker Mon and vague lists his
favorite features networked web-based
services make it possible to call of
vehicle status information manage
assignments and even monitor the cargo
area all these data can also be called
up remotely everything you need is right
on board when it comes to driver assists
the crosswind brake cross traffic and
active Lane Keeping Assist come as
standard for vehicles exceeding 3.5
metric tons - Emmanuel the new
mercedes-benz Sprinter is just as
versatile as the challenges it must rise
to but other brands are also pursuing
the same global design concept in the
end it all comes down to one question
how much will it cost and Germany prices
start at just under 24,000 euros
[Music]